sunflowers strikingly simple to the eye
in reality an automatic highly
orchestrated machine
what can the sunflower teach us about
digital business automation this is the
nature of tech sunflowers have a son
seeking or heliotrope a cat that follows
the light of the Sun all day long
day after day this movement is automatic
that's the same as organizations who
automate business logic to become as
consistently responsive to customers as
the sunflower is to sunlight sunflowers
absorb light water and carbon dioxide
transforming them into energy and the
oxygen we breathe
continuing their cycle of growth into
new vibrant blossoms and seeds with
digital business automation
organizations can capture critical data
from documents and proactively manage
that content transforming it into
something usable and valuable within
your processes and like the bees who
pollinate from sunflower to sunflower
robotic process automation software let
you easily retrieve and move data
between various systems function doesn't
detract from beauty it serves to augment
and ensure every flowers performance at
peak efficiency just as digital business
automation ensures you can streamline
business operations and orchestrate
complex and 2.n workflows that's digital
business automation and this is the
nature of tech